this is the coastal town of mangla near
the bay of bengal it's part of an
ambitious plan by the bangladeshi
government to transform this area into a
refuge for those displaced by climate
change there are several other similar
towns around the country
sonya begum and her family are among the
many here who were forced to move here
to find jobs and a safer place to live
our village home was destroyed by a
storm so we moved here
even before there were too many
weather-related problems and it wasn't a
good place to live anymore we do face
some problems with commuting and getting
enough fresh water but it's much better
here
bangladesh already invests about three
billion dollar a year to address the
effect of climate change
in recent years bangladesh government
have spent considerable amount of
resources in developing mangala as a
climate model town it has invested in
businesses industries power plants and
other facilities as well as attract
foreign investment
the town's mayor sheikh abdulrahman says
there are other projects underway to
make life easier for people here that
includes an airport and the construction
of a rail line to connect the town to an
economic hub across the border in india
ships are coming trade is going on goods
are being produced and new jobs are
being created mongolia's port is active
which is why people are better off here
but rahman says much more still needs to
be done to help people who have been
displaced by climate change
the nearby rural areas suffered heavily
due to climate change river erosion and
high salinity have affected the farming
and shrimp cultivation which is why many
rural migrants are now settling in
mongol town
many women are able to find jobs here
and support their family
since the export processing zone and
other industries opened here it's become
easier to find jobs there weren't many
job opportunities before we've been
living here ever since we lost our home
in a storm
bangladesh has one of the fastest
growing economies in asia but the
climate-induced internal displacement
has become one of its biggest challenges
a model town like mangla offers some
hope and shows how those who have been
displaced by climate change can
transform their lives through new
initiatives and opportunities tanvi
choudhary al-jazeera bangla bangladesh